[музика]
ланскі краєзнавці
випивши українську так звучить пісня ой на
горе там жінку
звук вона не хору імені лисенка все 40
співакова хору нідерландських кулак ти
навесні вже 20 рокер і його репертуар
складається
ви клеш нас українських писань
українські оперні співак ядра гент
мирослав антонович у тисяча дев'ятсот
дев'яносто шостому уроці за знову for
імені Лисенка училище тюль and валь
теперішній директор і ось наші стали
сільського хору brembo scart піднімається
на репетицію українська вишиванка ручна
роботи
подавитися шкіряний учасник форуму та таку
у будинку вечері ковані крок 1 речі
c кадру ювілейного виступу на 23 години
рублів sing up for спи вам літургію в
кафедральному соборі утрехту
[оплески]
черв'яки тільки на тему вечора
знак калашник цілих до тюль and value
учасники фору приїжджають на репетицію
ярослав синявський запахом liqueur проте
конусі українську
ви вирішив до допомагати співака мис гамова
ю сі слова пісень за писання
нідерландську транслітерацію нові також
займусь і такі звуки і кованими дуже
гарно вимиваєте це дуже важко
за рублі не вид concerti grossi кулак ти
з прямого я на петром кум вдалу школу
риду помсти за сном на форуми русло
wand у нової дитини чи не в
івано-франківської області
крем тофу колектив і націю осадження в
нідерландах успішних вже ним українських
музичних закладемо корж же кілька
рази в Україні теж травня у яблуні і про
політичної жити околиці директор х
річки проголосувавши за на референдумі
рахунку асоціації україн-єс
пояс її чомусь фланців було проти
ми голосу вали про ти за сина у нас
низькооплачуваних воді і фантазії wog з
польші ми голосу вали прот іскін
шинного виділення зберігати його у приватних
сум для петренко економікою ми вона
голосували проти україни cybus protests
середині з табель 6 не знаємо прозвітувала
про там написано у воді про асоціацію я
проголосувала за тому, що ми не буду
боятися україна
думаю це дуже важливо, щоб українці
були разом з Європи люди проголосували
проти і їм не пояснили суть не
випробування
ранок поза хором імені лисенка виросла в
тур україну в астані нідерланди були в
україні
чеда під шапку російську офісі панує
українців їх багата друзів теж геть з
нетерпінням чекають на зу стригти звичай
владному дозі вигляді перуки на тис. ніж
за 1 жива краю на культуру як іван і
популяризує в Європі